幹部というのは最も信頼たる人物ってこと
なんです。笛え吹け人踊らずと自分が
いくらに笛え吹いても誰も踊ってくれ
なかったら何も意味がないわけで育成と
いうものに対してのこだわりがない会社の
やっぱり幹部は育たないよね。青木サの
人生学100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、幹部育成がうまくいかない
会社の共通点ということで、ま、これまで
もいろんな会社を見られてこられたと思う
んですけれども、幹部が育たない会社の、
ま、共通のポイントがあれば教えて
いただけますでしょうか?
シンプルにまず経営者自身が軸を持ってな
いってことやね。誰のために、何のために
なぜ経営するのか。で、その目的が利己的
な場合には
幹部もコミットメントできないよね。経営
者が対顧客、対社会、対社員に対して
誠実に向き合って本当に自分はいい会社に
していこうとで方針を明確に打ち出して警
方針に対して心1つにまとまってその幹部
はその組織の存在理由パーパス目的に対し
て一点の曇りもなくそれを成手達成しよう
として働くわけじゃない。だからそれが
非常にこう見えにくい。
軸が見えないで経営者がなんかこう売上
市場主義、利益市場主義
そこでね、例えば部合だとかその成果報酬
制度とかで、ま、ガンガンそれで追い込
むっていう会社もあるけれど、そ、その
幹部自体も自分の収入のために自分の部下
にプレッシャー与えたりして
るっていうことはやっぱり人が離職する
でしょ。で、結局組織大きくならないよね
。ちょっと厳しい表現すると経営者が頭
良くないんだと。戦略的じゃないもん。
まずは価値ある商品を作
るってことなんですよ。それから作ったら
売るっていうことなんですよ。そして作っ
て売って管理するんだから財務お金のこと
から始まってなんだろう。組織運営という
意味においてやっぱりいい人材を採用し
育成をするこだわり。そのやっぱり育成と
いうものに対してのこだわりがない会社
っていうのはやっぱり幹部は育たないよね
。あの、ま、うちの会社をね、例に上げる
ならば39期目に入ったわけだよね。で、
ま、取締略2人、それから、ま、
マネージャーも今育ってきて、1番の
ポイントは僕がその目指していることが
社員の視点から見ても、お客様の視点から
見ても、社会から見ても良いものだと思う
んですよ。だから幹部はこの組織の中で
役割を果たし、5年、10年先を見据えて
自分の目先の尊徳ではなくて一緒にその
理想に近づこうと努力してくれてると思う
んだよね。でもやっぱり人が育たない会社
ってA理市場主義だったり経営者自身が
例えば2代目3代目によくあるのは覚悟が
決まってない。うん。本当は自分は別に
この仕事やりたくなかったんだけどみたい
な。絶対後継者にしちゃいけない人間を
後継者にしてるケースな。うん。なん
だろう。こうリンとしたさ、筋が通ってな
いっていうか、ま、ふ抜けっていうかさ、
ダメなんのは。だからその引き受けなきゃ
よかったんだよ。そしたらだ、僕なんかは
もう20年かけて役員育ててるわけだから
。ま、2000ね、6年入社の橋本拓也、
2007年入社の高橋優が今取締まり役で
、そっから続々と今6人ぐらい執行役員
取締めこれから育てながら、ま、40期に
は次のアチューメント、世界の
アチューメントに飛躍していく。そういう
絵をしっかりと描きながら、ま、未来創像
合宿、今30数名参加して6グレード以上
のメンバーが定期的に集まって、ま、将来
の売上400億、経歴力80億を目指して
みんな今頑張ってくれてるけれど、増えふ
けど人を踊らずという言葉があるけれど、
自分がいくら熱心に増え吹いても誰も踊っ
てくれなかったら何も意味がないわけで、
だから僕はやっぱり魚を与えるようにも
釣り方を身付けさせていくっていうことが
やっぱり育成の鍵だと思ってるので、ま、
そこに向かって人を育ててきたってことか
な。僕はすごくある意味では優しいけど
厳しい上司だと思うんですよね。幻格だと
思います。うん。基準は決して低くしない
。
その基準にみんながやっぱり合わせていくので全体のレベルが上がるんだと思うけどな。
ありがとうございます。こう幹部を育てていくっていうことをこうよくおっしゃられたんですけどでもこの幹部っていうのを単なる役職がある人だけだとは思ってらっしゃらないと思うんですね。
なんかそのこの幹部っていうものをなんか
単にそのマネージャーとか役員って名前が
ついたその幹部だけを育ってる企業もあれ
ばがそうではなくって本当にそのま会社の
未来にコミットメントしてる人材を育て
られる企業っていうのもあると思うんです
けどなんかここの違いって何だと思われ
ますか?
目的の違いでしょ?僕は人格者育てようと
してんだから売上がる人間育てようとして
ないもんだからフィードバ厳しいじゃん。
人格者だから僕は育てようとしてんの。
なぜ教育基本法教育の目的にあるじゃない
。教育は人格の完成を目指し、平和的な
国家及び社会の形成者として心理と正義を
愛し、個人の価値を遠び、金労と責任をじ
、自主的精神に満ちた心身ともに健康な
国民の育成をきして行わなければ。これを
幹部って考えてんだよ。だから幹部という
のは最も信頼る人物ってことなんですよ。
それが僕でいうアチューメントピラミッド
の一貫性が通った人間を幹部って言ってる
だけなのよ。ま、一貫性通らない人間は
なんか病気の幹部だよか。幹部のこう
なんか病気の場所。幹部分かり。幹部です
。幹部。幹部の一バシッと通ってんだよ。
じゃ、それは別名信たる人物ということ
です。あいつは信頼たる人物だと。僕が
育てたい人間は信頼たる人物。信頼に値
する人間。あいつは信用できる。あいつは
信頼できる。いや、どういうこと?特とサ
がある人間だからそこ育てようとしてる僕
とほなもん数字のKPI、KPIとか言っ
てね、PDC回して売上予算の達成とだ、
1番良い例が昔あった話で地方拠点の幹部
が長事で合わして予算達成して自分の部下
が目標達成しなくて拠点の売上目標達成し
た時決算商用彼が予想していたよりも
低かった。その時俺文句言われたの。なん
で拠点の予算達成してるのにボーナス決算
書いんですか?まるまる君と君自分の部下
イエローカード出てんだろうと。部下の
目標達成を通して自分の目標を達成するの
がマネージャーの仕事だろうと。これ
アチュームメント定義してるよなと。
つまりマネージメンてというのは将来は
マネージャーは次は経営者なんだと。経営
っていうのは人を返して仕事を行う技術だ
から君はその経営者のミニ番なんだよと。
だから人を返して仕事を行う技術が不十分
なんだから君は職務を全倒してないと。だ
からこの数字なんだと。ちゃんと自分の
職務全倒してくれと。自分の部下を育てて
部下が目標達成をしている状態の中で自分
が小心昇格をするグレードが上がるで胸を
張って高い報酬が取れるそういう人材に
なって欲しいと思います。よろしい
でしょうかって言ったことあり
教育でしょ。そうじゃないと目標から上
だったらピラミッドで言うなら目標から上
ね
ビジョン目標計画日々の実践この目標から
上だったら数字達成してるんだからそれを
基熟にだから僕はなんで会社が成果報酬を
導入しないかて言うと営業にだけ部合が
ついたりすると管理部門が協力したくなく
なっちゃうんだよ。チームビルディングな
んだよ。僕のテーマはforザームワン
チームワンミッションできない英語言っ
ちゃったけどこれ大事なことなのよ。でも
なんだろう。僕も別に成人じゃないけれど
もさ、なんか社員とお客様と社会に対して
は
いい会社でありたいなと思ってカ取りはし
てきたよね。
社長のせ終わります。じゃんじゃん。はい、終わりです。ということです。全部社長が悪い。それだけ。はい。そう思います。
ありがとうございます。
はい。本当にそうなんだよ。うん。あのね、真心番って言うんだけど、やっぱりね、社員をね、大切にした方がいいよ。一緒に働いてくれてるんだから。
ありがたいじゃん。俺は絶対思う。そのありがたいなっていう気持ちが持てないから幹部が育たないんだよ。
別に幹部だって幹部なろう、幹部なろうと
思って幹部なってるわけじゃなくて、役割
を果たしていったら結果的に幹部なってる
わけで、でもなんで役割果たそうとした
かって言ったら社長が本気で理念の具限化
に向かってるから自分の役割だけは
ちゃんと自分も社長も頑張ってる。立
頑張ってるから自分も頑張ろうって頑張る
わけでで喜んでもらいたいとかあこんなに
ちゃんと評価してくれるんならもっと社長
のに喜んでもらいたいとかもっと仲間に
喜んでもらいたいとかもっとね社会に
役立って喜んでもらいたいとかお客さんに
喜んでもらいたいとかまシテはそういう
気持ちの中からやっぱり家族から見ても
万弱な経
やっぱり見通しが持てる会社でやっぱり
いい状態でいや、俺でも本当もっともっと
休み増やしてあげたいと思ってるよ。本当
に本気で。だ、まずは有給を全部使う
ところから入ろうよっていうところだよな
。でもうちすげえ嬉しいのはなんか
やっぱりこう育面だとかさ、育面パパも
そうだけどいっぱい結構みんな自由に
休める本当に今いい会社になったよな。
いや、ありがとうな。本当うん。瞳が入社
した時っていうのはその当時の会社の状態
から見たら今もうまさにパラダイスだと
思いますよ。これ自分でもそう思うもん。
びっくりするぐらいいい会社になったなっ
て。でもそれはじゃあ僕がそうしたかって
言うとそうじゃなくてやっぱり幹部が
しっかりとなんだろうこの方針を受け止め
て一生懸命自分たちの中でいい会社に
しようというイメージを共有し続けて努力
してくれたおかげなんだよね。
だ、社長って今言ったけど、社長は方針とか方向だけはきちっと示すけど、ここはぶれないよね。でもやっぱりそういう組織を固めてくのはやっぱり幹部だもんな。それ無実もたなんじゃないか。
うん。
え、是非ね、え、コメントがあればコメントよろしくお願いします。プもよろしくお願いします。それからチャンネル登録していただけると嬉しいです。また次回おめに帰りましょう。ありがとうございます。
ま、逆に言うと聞いてみたい。あの、15
年入社して15年働いてて、ま、もう
明らかに岡口はアチューメントを背負う
大幹部の1人になってるんだけど、あなた
はなぜこの推しも押されもせぬこの大幹部
に成長できたんでしょうか?教えて
ください。興味があります。私いきなり
こっから質問にしましょう。
すごい無茶ぶりをありがとうございます。社長。
え、でも、ま、私がこう、ま、どう育ったかというよりはアチーブメントが多分どういうやっぱりその推出やその文化があったのかということを、まあ、なんか改めてこう考えますと、やっぱりその青木社長今おっしゃられたんですけれどもやっぱ経営者がぶれてないっていうことが
番大事でしょっていう風におっしゃられた。
やっぱその本質がぶれないっていうこのやっぱりどこにこの会社は向かっていきますかて言われた時に教育の力でやっぱり世界を変えることですし本当にその教育というものを使って本当にそのじめだったり差別だったりこう世の中が良くなるっていうことをどうしたら作れるかっていうここにま向かうこには曇りがないなんかその
どうこういろんな人がどう弊を見てるか分からないですけれども例えばですけど具体
の試作で見たらやっぱりその記者長がおっしゃられるようにちょっと前まではあの
3日休日あのうんうんうん
週3
日お休みにしようっていうことを言ってたのを最近はなくなったんだよなっていうことをおっしゃられたりとかしてるようなその私作のこう調礼解ってあのいっぱいあると思ってましてでもやっぱそれがブれてるとはやっぱり思わない水質があるだからそれはあくまでもその本当に向かいたい方向に向かい続けるためのう
は変わっていいでも目的地は変わらないっていうなんかここが結局そのアチーブメントが人が育つなんか文化を作れてる最大なのかなっていう風には思いますね。
なるほどね。うん。うん。うん。ま、すごく大事にしてきたね。で、僕はやっぱり本音も建前もないのでいいや本当あの幹部になりきれないでやっぱやめてく人もいたじゃん。
そういう人ってどういうところに今残って幹部になった人間と何が違う?
もちろんそのなんて言うんでしょう?その能力がま、え、ま、実力という意味で実力をこう歯気組みなかったっていう方ももちろん中にはいらっしゃったとは思うんですけれども、ただそのどちらかというとやっぱり目的地が違ったなっていう風には感じることがすごくありましてやっぱりその私たちが本当に向かっていきたいこの会社がどこに到達したいか
こと以上にやっぱりその個人としてこう
いう能力を身につけたいですとか個人とし
てこういう役職につきたいとかいくら
稼ぎたいっていうこのがまなん言ってん
ですかね強すぎるというか会社と違う方向
に向かってる方っていうのは幹部にはなら
なかったのかなっていう風には思いますね
。うん。やっぱりね、寂しい思いを
いっぱいしてきたけど、いや、もっと言う
とこうやって喋りながらごめんねって
気持ちをやっぱここから湧くんだよね。
もっとね、もっと力になってあげれたら
失わなくて住んだ人がいたかもしれない
なって。だからいつもやっぱり相手が悪い
んじゃなくて自分の努力不足というかいら
なさ
故えに人を失ってきたなっていうのが僕の
偽らざる気持ちですよね。でもその気持ち
ゆえにやっぱり残った人たちはそういう僕
の本質的な性格を知ってるから社長悲しま
せたくないなと思って頑張ってくれてる人
もたくさんいるような気がするのよ。いや
、どこにも理想の会社なんかないと思うん
だよ、俺。ユートピアって自分が作り出し
てくものでしょ。自分の心の中に。ま、
この年齢になってようやくだもんな。
ようやく
一応手をなしてきたかなみたいな。
ちょっとね、あそこの会社はなんであんな
に社員のモチベーション高くなんで人が
育つのか研究しようよという研究材料に
なるような気がする。そこまで行ったら
うちは
まさに人材教育のアチュメントですよ。今
はまだチャレンジャーです。はい。って
いう感じ。っていう間にもうどんどんね、
年齢は積み上げてんだ